now how about this leave my gas stove my
air conditioner my light bulbs red meat
SUV and especially my toilet paper alone
here with reaction author of the
upcoming book Serenity in the storm uh
the one and only outnumbered co-host
Kaylee mcinany
okay founder clay Travis
I want my gas stove I want my air
conditioner I want my red meat I eat
paleo leave my toilet paper alone yes I
mean well said I never thought we'd have
to say it me either as all of this is
happening what
welcome to Hannity it's a whole new
world it is but what's happening across
the world right I mean China's brokering
relations between Saudi Arabia and Iran
uh China's telling house Speaker
McCarthy you know you're severely
interfering with our decisions China's
completely polluting like far more than
we would ever do but we're focused on
the days and toilet paper really we
should be focusing on China but bidets
and toilet paper that's the priority of
Joe Biden that's well said you know Clay
look I believe in Freedom if liberals
prefer
I will allow them to make their own
choice they can use leaves
instead of toilet paper or they could
use nothing
nobody wants to be near them they won't
want to be near them even more I mean
where does this come I just hope they
don't get the wrong leaves right Sean
would end up with poison ivy look I feel
like uh I'm ahead of the curve because
uh if it happens it happens you know
accidents like that occur
that's the danger of camping outright I
feel like I've never been so convinced
that Tennessee's ahead of the curve Sean
we're going to bring back outhouses uh
and uh and everybody's going to point
out uh how brilliant we were for for so
long the green new deal just go out in
the backyard uh grab some poison ivies
or outhouses and you'll be ready to go
um and I just I'm with Kaylee by the way
we might be about to start World War III
and Democrats are trying to figure out
whether or not we can use toilet paper
and uh and also be able to eat whatever
we want and maybe World War III what did
Einstein say the World War IV would be
fought with uh with sticks and stones
right so maybe toilet paper is going to
be a luxury after Taiwan and Russia and
we end up with a war uh World War III
there this is the optimistic portion of
the Sean Hannity Show um
you know where did they come up with
this yeah you know the Paris climate
Accord that was a brilliant idea of the
left oh and Davos Switzerland right and
it allowed China to build factors amid
CO2 but the United States we paid their
developing nations they're developing
Nation but president Trump said I'm the
president of Pittsburgh not Paris and
that's what a president should be and
you know what
I'm saying any better uh clay great to
see you uh and I have forgiven your 500
debt it's wiped off the books you're
done uh anyway thank you both for being
with us Kaylee thank you clay Travis
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else